bonsoir et bienvenue à tous voici les
titres de l'actualité de ce mardi alors
que le froid s'installe en france
françois fillon tente de déminer la
crise sur les places d'hébergement il
propose un contrat aux associations pour
le mois de janvier avec nous ce soir
augustin legrand porte-parole des
enfants de don quichotte bonsoir et à
tout à l'heure c'était un test attendu à
la veille de l'examen de la loi sur le
pouvoir d'achat les salariés de l'usiné
continental en moselle ont massivement
voté le retour aux 40 heures et le
rachat de plusieurs jours de rtt
la montée du niveau de la mer pourrait
être plus rapide que prévu une nouvelle
étude qui divise les scientifiques
parlent d'une hausse possible d'un mètre
60 d'ici à la fin du siècle
certaines côtes françaises sont déjà
touchés en colombie les rebelles des
farc ont annoncé la libération de trois
otages parmi lesquels clara rojas ex
collaboratrices d'ingrid betancourt
l'information n'a pas encore été
confirmée par les autorités de bogota à
cuba fidel castro fait allusion pour la
première fois à son départ après 48 ans
au pouvoir et 16 mois de maladie il
évoque l'arrivée d'une nouvelle
génération
enfin c'était un autre siècle il ya
quarante ans tout juste la pilule était
autorisée en france par la loi neuwirth
on verra qu'aujourd'hui elle reste le
moyen de contraception principal utilisé
par 60% des femmes
le froid s'installe donc sur la france
les températures seront encore négatives
partout demain matin sauf sur les bords
de la méditerranée
c'est dans ce contexte que françois
fillon veut donc tenter de mettre fin à
la polémique sur l'hébergement qui dure
depuis plusieurs jours il a reçu les
associations d aide aux sans logis
reconnu que toutes les promesses
n'étaient pas réalisés et proposer un
contrat qui sera signé le 15 janvier
alix bouilhaguet christian leroux ces
deux là ne se parlaient plus que par
chiffres interposés et contradictoires
depuis quelques jours la ministre du
logement et le porte parole des enfants
de don quichotte celui bras une bataille
de chiffres en cause le nombre de places
d'hébergement disponibles pour les sdf
pour calmer les ardeurs de chacun tous
les acteurs du dossier ont été convoqués
à matignon
mandela solidaire
le gouvernement reconnaît qu'il doit
faire un effort sur les 12000 places de
maisons relais promines seuls 6000 ont
été réalisés françois fillon engage a
convié retard la mise en oeuvre de cette
loi et la mise en oeuvre de ce plan ne
sont pas faciles il se heurte à des
résistances et des objets et à des
obstacles on est d'accord avec les
associations pour trouver ensemble les
moyens de réduire complètement ces
obstacles
demain un parlementaire va être nommé
pour rédiger un contrat entre les
associations et le gouvernement
à l'intérieur des objectifs précis
chiffrés anker mettre en regard les
demandes des associations avec l'argent
de l'état
les mesures existent seule manque la
volonté politique c'est ce sur quoi nous
avons assisté donc ce le cas janvier
nous verrons bien
c'est cette fois ci la volonté politique
sera au rendez vous pas il va leur
destin legrand semble être d'accord sur
la méthode tous se retrouveront donc le
15 janvier à matignon pour signer ce
contrat si tout se passe bien alors on
l'a compris au delà des places d'urgence
l'enjeu essentiel concerne l'hébergement
plus durable qui vise à redonner une
chance aux sans abri il s'agit en
particulier de ces fameuses maisons
relais ou de structures équivalentes
dont plusieurs dizaines fonctionne déjà
mais elles sont souvent pleines voici
pourquoi
a lyon reportage benoît gadret philippe
évêques il a tout juste 23 ans
son regard en dit long sur l'épreuve
qu'ils traversent
pendant plusieurs mois karim a connu la
rue les nuits passées dans les
hébergements d'urgence
franchement c'est assez dur
après c'est pas allongement c'est ça il
y aura des angoisses
j'étais inquiète c'est ça il ya neuf
mois
karim a enfin trouvé un toit provisoire
une chambre dans cette résidence gérée
par l'association notre dame des sans
abri voilà c'est là où j'habite
la petite chambre gmail à élire monde y
passe la salle de bain l'espace est
exigu mais bien aménagé confortable
l'immeuble a été entièrement rénové on
est loin du froid on est loin de voilà
dans les rangs sécurité on est vous êtes
aidez voilà la résidence un ancien hôtel
accueille 140 personnes des jeunes mais
aussi des personnes plus âgées
patrick à 58 ans il était routier et
sans domicile fixe après tout ce qui
m'arrive et les galères et ainsi de
suite
c'est une chance qui m'est re de
redonner pour elle pour reprendre goût à
la vie reprendre goût trouver un travail
et surtout un logement autonome et vous
avez que déjà pris des contacts
également pour cela les résidents sont
suivis par l'association karim a
décroché un contrat à temps partiel
reste le problème du logement
malheureusement ni logement dans le parc
public ni logements dans le parc privé
accessible à nos jeunes parce qu'ils
sont trop chers parce que les bailleurs
réclament également des gares ou faute
de logements disponibles
le séjour qui devait être provisoire
dure au détriment des nombreux sans abri
qui attendent d'être admis dans la
résidence
comme promis nous retrouvons maintenant
en duplex du pont d'austerlitz à paris
augustin legrand porte-parole des
enfants de don quichotte
bonsoir vous participiez à cette réunion
et françois fillon est ce que la
polémique est close
est ce que vous êtes satisfait après
cette réunion est la promesse d'un
accord le 15 janvier je crois que c'est
nécessaire de clore cette polémique qui
a été très néfastes pour l'ensemble des
associations puisqu'on a remis en cause
notre diagnostic commun partagé par
l'ensemble monsieur fillon a arbitré je
crois que c'est très bien les choses
maintenant son
plus clair on rentre dans une phase de
négociation pour deux choses la première
chose tenir les objectifs de campagne de
monsieur sarkozy c'est que à la fin de
l'année prochaine plus personne ne soit
contraint de dormir dehors donc ça veut
dire proposer à l'ensemble des personnes
qui sont dehors aujourd'hui des
solutions adaptées où elles veulent bien
y aller
la deuxième chose c'est d'éviter de
fabriquer des sans abri ça veut dire que
le droit au logement opposable votée une
loi effective tax et passent six cent
mille ménages qui vont réclamer devant
les commissions du logement parce que le
préfet en face n'a que 60 mille
logements attribués
donc ça c'est très clair qu'il faut des
opérations tiroirs il en existe de
location massif dans parc privé pour
faire du logement social c'est immédiat
on n'a pas besoin d'attendre du bâti à 2
millions d'appartements et de logement
si chaque année sont libres sur le
marché alors il ya des solutions qui
existent les l'ensemble les experts et
l'ensemble des associations ont présenté
30 cette mesure sur le bureau du
président sarkozy il faut les chiffres
et les budgétés et les appliquer est ce
que ça signifie dans l'immédiat que vous
renoncez pour cet hiver aux opérations
de villages de tentes comme celle du
week-end dernier sur les quais de notre
dame à paris
écoutez on verra bien où en sont les
négociations je crois que il fera de
polémique nous ce qu'on a essayé de
faire ce week-end c'est de mettre à
l'abri des gens dans des conditions plus
dignes que du caniveau ou plus digne
même que du gymnase où on est face à des
grands exclus qui évidemment avec des
preuves d'insécurité c'est absolument
pas digne on veut mettre à l'abri les
gens pendant 15 jours pendant la vague
de froid
on va les ressortir dehors ces gens là
ne veulent pas ces solutions qui sont
des solutions complètement indigne
maintenant il faut bien comprendre qu'on
n'est pas des activistes
on a essayé mais travailler des gens
dans les jardins notre dame on a mis
aussi un village de tente au bord de la
seine voilà on s'est fait évacuer et il
n'est pas exclu une nouvelle opération à
présent alors vous savez on verra bien
où on en est je crois que le
gouvernement doit lancer une vraie
politique publique du logement on le
réclame il faut arrêter de communiquer
maintenant il faut agir
les français sont très attentifs vous
savez il ya un français sur deux
capteurs de devenir sans abri
je crois que cette promesse qui a été
faite par monsieur sarkozy pendant la
campagne a été entendu par tous ces gens
qui ont peur et je crois que ça dépasse
tous les clivages partisans
il faut agir vite c'est bon pour la
cohésion sociale c'est bon pour notre
pays
c'est bon pour notre économie et c'est
bon pour tous les jeunes notamment celui
qu'on vient d'entendre reportage vous
savez la revue ça abîme ça coûterait
cher de récupérer les gens après
quelques mois dans la rue il faut agir
en amont il fait dans la prévention
et puis faut surtout respecter ces gens
qui sont des citoyens comme vous et moi
merci augustin legrand d'avoir été avec
nous ce soir on en vient au projet de
loi sur le pouvoir d'achat il sera
discuté je vous le disais à partir de
demain en séance plénière à l'assemblée
on va y venir dans un instant mais
d'abord le résultat très attendu dans ce
contexte du vote des 1300 salariés de
l'usiné de pneus continental de
sarreguemines et bien ils ont voté
massivement pour le retour aux 40 heures
et pour le rachat de plusieurs jours de
rtt sur place christine bosse entre le
stade schmitt le chiffre s'affiche à
l'entrée du site
74% des 1400 salariés ont dit oui à
l'allongement du temps de travail sans
état d'âme
et pour cause votre sens avait été très
clair avec nous aussi si lui ne sortait
poche pour ce qu'on n'aura pas duré deux
ans plus tard on n'avait pas trop le
choix c'était ça ou enfermés bientôt
soumise à une forte concurrence
internationale usine continental de
sarreguemines doit améliorer sa
compétitivité
depuis dimanche les salariés étaient
invités à se prononcer sur un projet de
développement d'entreprise baptisé
donnant gagnant au menu un renoncement
partiel ou rtt des jours fériés
travaillés en échange d'une augmentation
salariale de six pour cent
opération réussie pour la direction une
des qualités majeures pour être un
acteur important de la vie économique
c'est d'être capable d'être à date
adaptable et je crois que là nous
salariés ont montré qu'ils avaient cette
volonté de faire l'effort de changer au
bon moment très critique sur le
référendum
les syndicats reconnaissent que
l'augmentation salariale et la promesse
d'une prime ont pu influencer le vote
c'est sûrement un élément qui a joué
dans un cas pense qu'en présentant quand
même une augmentation qui se situerait
autour de 87 euros par mois par salarié
ce qui n'est pas négligeable ça a
sûrement joué dans le choix des
personnes les syndicats vont à présent
devoir négocier un accord la direction a
promis l'embauché de 50 personnes
objectif produire 200 mille tonnes
supplémentaires par an l'examen du texte
sur le pouvoir d'achat commencera donc
demain pour les députés
d'ores et déjà les possibilités de
rachat de rtt ont été étendues lors de
discussions préliminaires en commission
les amendements ont été adoptés les
seuils et les dates butoirs ont été
assouplies yassine benzia net philippe
chassaing
c'était prévu raw aux usines c'est la
grande question dans les entreprises
comment va se passer le rachat des rtt
dans le projet du gouvernement
au 31 décembre prochain s'il restaient
au plus dix jours de rtt à prendre il
pouvait être racheté
les députés de la majorité veulent aller
plus loin tous les jours de rtt qui
seraient accumulés jusqu'au 30 juin 2008
serait monétisable ça veut dire que bien
sûr ça résultait de l'accord entre
l'entrepreneur le patron et le salarié
mais pour l'opposition un problème
demeure les heures supplémentaires sont
payées 25% de plus qu'une heure normale
les rtt quant à elles ne seraient
racheter que 10% de plus la disposition
proposée est moins favorable aux
salariés plus favorable au chef
d'entreprise est plus favorable aussi à
l'état puisque moins coûteuse et jean
lucas n'a pas pris du tout un salarié
sur trois à des rtt mais impossible de
savoir combien seront concernés par leur
rachat cela dépendra des accords signés
et du bon vouloir du chef d'entreprise
toujours dans l'actualité sociale cette
dernière minute les syndicats de
fonctionnaires qui étaient réunis ce
soir viennent de décider d'une grève le
24 janvier prochain
donc dans un peu plus de cinq semaines
grève pour les salaires hier on
l'évoquait le gouvernement a refusé
toute augmentation générale des salaires
des images signe arnaud auguste grève
donc à l'appel des syndicats de
fonctionnaires ce sera le 24 janvier
économie et justice avec une affaire
sans doute révélatrices d'un climat
vous vous souvenez certainement de cette
stagiaire chinoises soupçonnaient
d'avoir jouer les espionnes dans
l'entreprise valeo il y a deux ans eh
bien le tribunal a rendu son jugement
aujourd'hui la jeune fille a certes été
condamné pour avoir téléchargé un
fichier confidentiel mais elle est
blanchi de tout soupçon d'espionnage sa
nationalité chinoise avait sans doute
joué contre elle olivier caroff marie
cazaux une mata hari déguisé en
stagiaires une plieuse de matière grise
il y a deux ans son visage symbolisait
le péril de l'espionnage industriel
aujourd'hui mademoiselle dit étudiante
chinoise vient d'être condamné à deux
mois de prison ferme pour abus de
confiance mais pas pour espionnage on en
parlait d' espionnage industriel
il ya un environnement espionnage
chinois
emploi le tout comme
il faut repas parental achim mai 2005
dans ses locaux de l'entreprise valeo
lily est en stage soudain l'entreprise
portent plainte contre elle copies de
dossiers ultra confidentiel destruction
de données
elle va passer 53 jours en détention
provisoire
ils sont les données trail confidentiel
auquel d'ailleurs la stagiaire n'avait
pas régulièrement accès et le site de la
mairie hier nous a dit nous dit on et
d'acide ultrasensible le procès a montré
qu'elle avait stocké des documents
confidentiels certes mais peu sensible
les autres stagiaires y avaient accès
elle a eu le tort de les copier pour
travailler chez elle valeo at il crié à
l'espionnage un peu vite
son avocat n'a pas souhaité nous
répondre pour l'université de compiègne
où mademoiselle lee fait ses études ne
lui a jamais retiré sa confiance
il ya quelques semaines elle a reçu son
diplôme le parrain de sa promotion
le patron de valeo qui s'est décommandé
juste avant la cérémonie la justice
encore c'est confirmé le tueur en série
francis heaulme a bien bénéficié d'un
non-lieu dans le double meurtre des deux
garçonnets de montigny les metz il ya 21
ans
le juge d'instruction estime qu'il n'y a
pas de charges suffisantes la sphère
reste donc irrésolu à ce jour
en bref un mort et 10 blessés dont 3
graves dans un nouvel incendie la nuit
dernière à paris
le feu a pris pour des raisons inconnues
dans l'escalier de cet immeuble de six
étages du xviie arrondissement
une nouvelle étude sur la montée du
niveau de la mer elle indique que les
prévisions réalisées jusque là sont
peut-être trop optimiste la fonte des
glaces au groenland très difficile à
prévoir pourrait entraîner une hausse
d'un mètre 60 d'ici à la fin du siècle
ce travail divise les scientifiques la
france en tout cas pourrait reconsidérer
le risque pour son littoral
gilles marie née marie cazaux un paysage
et des animaux menacés de disparition
selon les travaux publiés par des
scientifiques allemands britanniques et
américains l'acca marque pourrait être
recouverte par les eaux d'ici la fin du
siècle et cela jusqu'aux portes de la
ville d'arles
en étudiant les vestiges laissés dans le
sol pendant une période de réchauffement
il ya 120 mille ans les chercheurs on en
déduit que le niveau des océans
monteraient d'un mètre 60 d'ici 2100
clair sur la france augmenté de rs 60 ça
serait extrêmement inquiétant peut-être
moins inquiétant pour nos voisins
britanniques ou hollandais ou par
ailleurs en plus le solde des 100 points
chez nous on n'a pas heureusement ce
problème là il n'empêche
en plus de la camargue une partie des
côtes du nord de la france de la manche
et de l'ouest atlantique serait
recouverte en france des dizaines
d'études sont en cours pour trouver les
meilleurs moyens comme ici dans le nord
de contrer la montée des eaux
il n'y a pas de réponse globale chaque
portion de côte a ses particularités
le temps presse tous les scientifiques
en sont d'accord
la fonte des calottes glaciaires
s'accélère bien au-delà des prévisions
est précisément nicolas sarkozy s'est
rendu en camargue aujourd'hui pour
réaffirmer qu'il tiendrait les
engagements pris lors du grenelle de
l'environnement
le président de la république accompagné
de jean-louis borloo en a profité vous
le voyez pour faire un tour à cheval et
mach signé stéphane guillemot une autre
région et non seulement menacée mais
déjà touché il s'agit de la guyane la
montée des eaux là bas a déjà englouti
plusieurs maisons de la commune de
rémire reportage alban nicosie avec les
équipes de rfo guyane
c'est le quartier résidentiel de cayenne
de jolies maisons avec une vue
imprenable sur l'océan atlantique une
vue imprenable c'est certain durable ça
l'est beaucoup moins
jour après jour l'océan grignote
inexorablement même à marée basse du
petit restaurant ouvert en 2005 il ne
reste que des ruines
il ya quinze jours c'est la maison des
bonnes soeurs qui a basculé
ces photos témoignent de la brutale
montée des eaux
pour les riverains c'est l' angoisse
d'autant que le phénomène semble
s'accélérer
claude pawlowski dit ici depuis toujours
sa maison est désormais en première
ligne
régulièrement il a recours aux services
d'une société de terrassement la
pelleteuse construit une digue de sable
qu'il faut sans cesse remontée et donne
à manger à la mer je lui donne du sabbat
elle adore ça cette partie de sable
qu'on est en train de faire mettre par
un engin comme vous voyez sert à ce que
la mère puce
donc je me répète manger ce sable avant
d'attaquer le terrain parce qu'elle en a
déjà assez pris assez comme ça on a déjà
perdu plus de 50 mètres ça suffit qu à
l'origine du phénomène la montée des
eaux de la planète doublé de l'érosion
accélérée de la baie les anciens se
souviennent de la mangrove qui s'étalait
sur plusieurs centaines de mètres
en 25 ans elle est totalement disparu et
la plage avec les vagues lèche les
maisons et les travaux de protection
vous coûter cher
les propriétaires appelle l'état au
secours alors quand même des retraités
qui n'ont pas les moyens de
faire ces travaux donc en demandez donc
au préfet le nous débloquer d'efforts
d'urgence le problème c'est que l'état
ne peut pas faire grand-chose renforcer
tel point du littoral avec des rochers
c'est en désigner d'autres à la colère
des océans la préfecture de guyane va
donc faire réaliser une étude d'urgence
je sais bien qu'il ya un an je sais très
bien qu'il ya des gens qui ont peur
qu'ils sont dans une situation difficile
mais il nous faut vraiment un minimum
d'expertisé minimum danalyse pour
pouvoir progresser sur ceux de siph avec
320 km de littoral la guyane n'échappe
pas aux conséquences de la montée des
océans 90% de la population vit au bord
de mer
autant dire que les prochaines grandes
marées prévues ici la veille de noël
sont observés avec inquiétude à
l'étranger d'abord la colombie on l'a
appris il y à moins d'une heure et c'est
peut-être un signe d'espoir les rebelles
des farc ont annoncé la libération de
trois otages trois otages parmi lesquels
clara rojas ex collaboratrices d'ingrid
betancourt et le fils qu'elle a eu lors
de sa détention l'information n'a pas
encore été confirmée par les autorités
de bogota
renaud bernard voici clara rojas à
gauche sur l'écran à côté d'ingrid
betancourt c'était quelques jours avant
leur enlèvement
la dernière preuve de vie de la
directrice de campagne d'ingrid
betancourt remonte à juillet 2002 la
voix si elle était restée silencieuse
aux côtés de son ami
selon l' agence de presse cubaine les
farc les forces armées révolutionnaires
de colombie viennent de décider de
libérer clara rojas
mais aussi son fils emmanuel né dans la
jungle après son enlèvement ainsi que la
parlementaire consuelo gonzalez tous les
trois serait remis au président
vénézuélien hugo chavez à caracas pour
les farc c'est une réparation pour les
familles des otages après que le
président uribe et mis fin à la
médiation d'hugo chavez
pour autant le président français la
communauté internationale si on n'a plus
rien on a mis à part l' agence de presse
cubaine la nouvelle de cette triple
libération n'a pas été confirmée par les
autorités colombiennes ou vénézuélienne
pour l'instant et à l'instant les farc
font savoir qu'elles jugent inacceptable
deux rencontres proposées par le
président colombien uribe alors nous
sommes en ligne avec fabrice de loi
merci d'être avec nous vous êtes l'ex
mari est d'ingrid betancourt d'abord est
ce que vous prenez cette information au
sérieux car elle n'a pas encore été
confirmée par les autorités colombiennes
oui à priori je l'apprends sérieux parce
que c'est tout à fait d'après le libellé
de ces informations c'est tout après le
langage qu'utilisent les facs
normalement donc il faut vérifier bien
entendu mais elle est sérieuse je crois
vous connaissez vous même clara rojas
je connais bien sûr clara oui et c'est
une très très bonne nouvelle de savoir
quel petit béret de savoir qu'elle sera
libérée que son enfant et puis également
que la sénatrice perdomo qui est malade
soit aussi libéré se trouve que c'est
extraordinaire et c'est un premier pas
très important dans la négociation qu'on
attend pour une zone dénucléarisée
les farc parle d'une zone de rencontre
inacceptable pour l'instant cela
signifie que cette libération serait
temps en pointillés oui non je ne pense
pas je pense que cette libération est un
geste et sera un geste unilatéral des
farc
c'est la première fois en six ans que
les farc font un geste unilatéral
ça veut dire que quelque part ils ont
compris les messages qui leur ont été
envoyés
il me fallait envoyer par le président
sarkozy les messages envoyés par les
émissaires qui vont les voir
régulièrement l'émissaire français et
l'émissaire suisse qui demandait
justement la libération de clara roja
fier de son bébé et ça prouve aussi que
les farc sont disposés à négocier
maintenant il reste que le président
uribe doit impérativement accepter
qu'une zone démilitarisée
merci beaucoup d'avoir été avec nous
pour cette première réaction monsieur de
loi à cuba c'est une première dans une
lettre lue à la télévision fidel castro
a fait allusion à son départ après 48
ans au pouvoir et 16 mois de maladie
il évoque l'arrivée possible d'une
nouvelle génération philippe rochot une
berceuse pour fidel castro chanté par un
grand admirateur le président du
venezuela hugo chavez
c'était la dernière image du lider
maximo pour ses 80 ans l'été dernier un
homme fatigué malade qui a fait lire
hier soir cette lettre à la télévision
où il promet de céder la place mon
devoir n'est pas de m'accrocher à des
fonctions
encore moins de fermer la porte à des
personnes plus jeunes mais d'apporter
mon expérience
la nouvelle d'un retrait possible n'a
guère surpris les cubains il a fait son
testament et nous a montré la direction
à suivre
je ne pense pas que tu bats changera
même avec un autre chef n'ont pas facile
d'admettre qu'il faudra quitter un jour
ce pouvoir absolu qui a commencé en 59
avec le débarquement d'une poignée de
barbudo ce qui chasse le dictateur
batista mais castro tient tête à
l'amérique depuis plus de 40 ans des
milliers de cubains ont répondu à sa
politique en gagnant les états unis mais
malgré cela et malgré la maladie castro
s'accroche encore au pouvoir
son frère raul assure la continuité
une affaire de famille mais castro sera
quand même candidat aux législatives de
janvier ce qui lui donne la possibilité
de se représenter or mars sa lettre
n'est peut être qu'une fausse sortie
en bref la fin du voyage du colonel
kadhafi en espagne
en comparaison avec la france on peut
parler de visite d'agrément pas de
polémique ni dans la presse ni dans la
classe politique le colonel kadhafi qui
a passé quatre jours outre pyrénées a
été reçu par le roi et par le premier
ministre c'est luis zapatero il a été
question de promesses de contrats à
hauteur de 12 milliards d'euros
des images toujours impressionnante le
temps fort du pèlerinage à la mecque des
millions de pèlerins musulmans sont
rassemblés sur la plaine d'arafat il
s'agit de la plus grande manifestation
religieuse au monde et parmi eux un
invité de marque entre
mais le président de l'iran mahmoud
ahmadinejad premier pays chiite du monde
il a été invité par le roi abdallah
c'est une première
la recette italienne pour régulariser
les clandestins maintenant chaque année
désormais une loterie entre guillemets
est ouverte aux sans papiers cette année
170 mille titres de séjour vont être
distribués philippe visseyrias mustapha
coyah top départ 8h du matin dans les
locaux du syndicat cgl de rome nord
la connexion avec le ministère de
l'intérieur vient à peine de s'établir
le destin de milliers de travailleurs
clandestins se joue dans ces premières
minutes
trois ordinateurs fonctionnent en même
temps et transmettre un à un les
dossiers des candidats de l'internet
parmi 70 postes de travail offert cette
année par le gouvernement des syndicats
qui centralise les candidatures via
internet afin d'éviter ces images des
files d'attentes interminables chaque
année devant les bureaux de poste pour
les candidats à la régularisation
l'immigration par quotas en italie une
politique entamée par le gouvernement de
droite de silvio berlusconi est
poursuivi actuellement par le
gouvernement de gauche de romano prodi
ne pensons pas qu'il faille régulariser
tous les clandestins présents
actuellement en italie parce que ça crée
une nouvelle vague d'arrivées
d'étrangers sans papiers
fabienne et équatorien dix ans il vit à
rome clandestinement et s'occupent d'une
personne invalide
cette fois ci il a bon espoir d'être
régularisés la moitié des postes
proposés concernent des emplois des
aides à domicile sur mon dossier de
candidature repose tout mon espoir est
mon avenir
certes c'est une loterie mais elle
pourrait bien me porter chance
fabien on devra attendre quarante jours
avant de savoir s'il fait partie des 170
mille dossiers sélectionnés par
l'ordinateur du ministère de l'intérieur
ce matin les fonctionnaires de ce
ministère on précisait qu'il
n'utiliserait pas les données fournies
par les candidats afin d'expulser ceux
dont le dossier sera refusé rien
qu'entre samedi dernier aujourd'hui cinq
cent dix neuf mille travailleurs
clandestins se sont déjà portés
candidats pour être régularisés de quoi
donner une idée de l'ampleur du
phénomène
l'immigration clandestine en italie aux
états unis un nouvel et aboli la peine
de mort il s'agit du new-jersey en fait
aucune exécution n'a eu lieu là bas
depuis 40 ans nos correspondants alain
de chalvron et marjolaine grappes ont pu
rencontrer un ancien bourreau il a
exercé pendant dix sept ans en virginie
il s'exprime pour la première fois
devant une caméra
voici ce reportage c'est rare très rare
qu'un bourreau parle gerig evans n'a
jamais parlé
il a pourtant un palmarès si l'on peut
dire éloquent 62 exécution entre 1982 et
99 dans cette prison de virginie
quand on lui demande s'il est fier de
son métier sa réponse fuse non non pas
vraiment jerry given a connu la chaise
électrique au début de sa carrière
puis il est passé à l'exécution par
injection létale réputé plus douce ce
n'est pas tout à fait l'avis du
professionnel qu'il est je choisirais
plutôt lâché m
pourquoi parce que c'est rapide c'est
comme allumer ou à la lune
il faut dire que jerry qu'evans n'a
jamais eu de formation il fixer lui-même
au juge et la dose injectée le résultat
n'était pas toujours satisfaisant sauf
qu'entre temps en floride l'an dernier
se condamner à mort à agoniser dans de
terribles douleurs pendant une demi
heure
el cheikh ça fait bouger dans tous les
sens ses yeux était révulsée comme s'ils
souffraient si le président du jury est
lui-même le bourreau le juge était celui
qui appuie sur la seringue
j'y réfléchirai à deux fois avant de
condamner quelqu'un à la mort la
constitution américaine prévoit qu'une
peine ne peut pas être je cite cruel la
cour suprême devrait donc statué l'an
prochain sur la légalité du mode
d'exécution par injection létale
on pourrait donc se retrouver dans cette
situation absurde où la peine de mort
serait légale mais le mode d'exécution
art illégal retour en france avec un
anniversaire il ya quarante ans tout
juste la pilule était autorisée par la
loi neuwirth une révolution dans les
comportements bien sûr aujourd'hui elle
reste le moyen de contraception
principal utilisé par 60% des femmes
mais les plus jeunes comment ça en vous
hors des limites c'est le dossier de
cette édition il est signé anne guéris
s'ils vendent au bas à la porte du lycée
entre les notes du dernier contrôle et
la sortie du week-end prochain
la pilule et pour les filles un sujet de
conversation largement partagé la pilule
dont elle dit surtout que ce n'est pas
la panacée
bon c'est sûr que c'est pas pratique
parce qu'il faut y penser tous les jours
et on verra mais comme un bon moyen ça à
éviter des problèmes mais est ce que
c'est vraiment la meilleure solution
surtout quand ils sont mauvais pour la
santé
quarante ans après voilà donc que les
jeunes filles bout de la pilule et dire
que leur mère en ont tant rêver
sa formidable vous prenez la pilule
depuis combien de temps cela fait trois
mois je pense que je travaille je peux
parler d'un deuxième emprunt ce jeune
mariée j'ai eu un bébé un petit peu trop
tôt à mon avis est que j'aimerais en
avoir un dans plusieurs villes l'heure
est désormais venue de passer de la
maternité accidentelle à la maternité
consciente et responsable
ainsi 19 décembre 1967 la législation de
la contraception est votée au parlement
arrachée de haute lutte par le député
gaulliste lucien neuwirth un fossoyeur
d'enfants dira de lui son propre camp
l'hostilité dans l'hémicycle mais aussi
chez les médecins
monique moisson n'oubliera jamais la
réaction de son gynécologue
quand en 1969 elle a osé lui demander la
pilule sa première réaction c'est qu'il
était scandalisé par ce que il a tout de
suite pensé pilule dévergondage et puis
ensuite il m'a décrit tous les effets
secondaires dont certains d'ailleurs
dont on n'avait jamais parlé pour me
menacer des pierres qualité aujourd'hui
60 % des françaises prennent la pilule
20 % optent pour le stérilet 11% pour le
préservatif
la france a bel et bien le taux de
contraception le plus élevé en europe
mais paradoxe il y a toujours autant
d'interruption volontaire de grossesse
210000 ivg par an dont treize mille
quatre cent chez les mineurs pour ce
médecin
il faut donc adapter les moyens de
contraception à chaque jeune fille une
jeune fille qui est très très structuré
qui il faut lui proposer pourquoi pas à
comprimer comprend tous les jours mais
une jeune fille qui était en l'air il
faut pas lui proposer quelque chose
qu'elle va oublier de prendre tous les
soirs se souvenir trois jours après
qu'elle a oublié courir aller prendre
une pilule du lendemain non non ça peut
pas aller
c'est donc le sens de cette campagne
d'information diffusée depuis septembre
faire connaître aux plus jeunes un large
éventail de méthodes contraceptives
à quelques jours des vacances peut être
du nouveau pour les tv leur gestion
devrait être privatisée y compris pour
le stationnement les contractuels ne
serait donc plus des agents municipaux
mais des employés de sociétés la réforme
vient d'obtenir le feu vert
elle ne concernerait tout de même pas
tous les procès verbaux hakim abdel
khaleq pascal caron
la fin les pervenches et peut être
programmé la prune le papillon bref le
pv pourrait bientôt être privatisée
jusqu'à présent le procès verbal pour
non paiement de stationnement un prix
unique fixé encaissés par l'état 11
euros mais la majorité envisage
sérieusement d'en confier la gestion aux
mairies les pv serait alors distribuées
par des sociétés privées et leur montant
pourrait augmenter les villes ont envie
de récupérer directement l'argent des
automobilistes qui stationnent
illégalement et qui se disent plutôt que
ça aille dans les caisses de l'état
autant le garder pour la ville qui a dit
travaux à faire comme si j y construire
un tramway et des parkings
supplémentaires d aménagement urbain la
ville de paris par exemple attend avec
impatience cette recette supplémentaire
elle a même déjà prévu le prix de ces
futurs pv autour de 20 25 euros
voilà à peu près ce qu'on parle de façon
à ce que il y a une meilleure dissuasion
et peut encore une fois les
automobilistes payent
normalement le droit de pouvoir
stationner évidemment les automobilistes
ne partage pas vraiment cet enthousiasme
c'est pas possible en restant déjà assez
élevé comme ça c est une farce c'est
lamentable
ce sera de plus en plus difficile
d'avoir une voiture à paris c'est déjà
compliqué mais ce sera de plus en plus
difficile des pv distribués par des
sociétés privées
le système existe déjà à londres le
nombre d'amendés a explosé dans la
capitale britannique les employés sont
payés à la commission plus ils
verbalisent plus ils sont payés un
procédé radical qui n'est toutefois pas
encore envisagée en france à la veille
de noël vous vous apprêtez peut-être à
manger des huîtres est bien une nouvelle
technique est en vogue chez les
ostréiculteurs l'élevage en pleine mer
sur de longs filets les huîtres se
développe beaucoup plus vite
reportage jeune guy ep alain darrigrand
un grand filet comme une grande
chaussette baptisé la lanterne
à l'intérieur les huîtres de noël voilà
là on est en train de découper les
filets pour libérer les unes des
plateaux un très beau cadeau il dit en
un temps record pour les amis assez
grosse heure là il ya quatre mois et on
ressort 18 comme ça un nom c'est sionnel
d'habitude se laisseront nous aurait
fallu encore un peu pour un an et demi
en pleine mer les huîtres grossistes
quatre à sept fois plus vite que sur les
tables de l'estran comme celle-ci
régulièrement découverte par la marée
les ostréiculteurs ont attendu dix ans
avant d'obtenir une concession maritime
12 kilomètres carrés enfin accordés par
l'état
le principe des grands filets fermer les
lanternes accroché à un filin le tout
stabiliser par des blocs en béton au
fond de la mer
riches en plancton à manche tout le
temps 24 heures sur 24 tous les jours
tous les jours tous les jours à son
émergence renault c'est cet ingénieur
qui a mis au point les filières son idée
produire de grosses quantités pour
l'agroalimentaire par exemple des 800
copies vendus en barquette au niveau
mondial 80% des huit sont consommés
transformer en europe 0 kg donc on a
quand même un marché potentiel très
important à condition d'avoir le produit
destiné à transformation la production
d'huîtres pourrait ainsi triplé en dix
ans une révolution pour le strict
culture encore très artisanal cinéma
vanessa paradis marie gillain guillaume
canet jean rochefort josiane balasko ou
encore thierry lhermitte c'est la
distribution prestigieuse d'un film qui
sort demain la clé un polar sombre sur
fond de machination marie-jo jouant
jean-marie le quartier
je la sens
et je n'ai pas l'habitude simplement que
tout cas qui se délite vinson et
l'averse d'un héros un jeune homme
ordinaire qui refuse de s'engager auprès
de la femme qu'il aime tant qu'il n'a
pas retrouvé le père qu'il n'a pas connu
sans qu'il a un passé très lourd qui ne
veut pas failli à des cartons et les
deux c'est qu'il veut surtout pas ouvrir
et que ça va forcément lui pète à la
gueule quand il fallait ouvrir film noir
oblige cette quête plus ordinaire va le
plonger dans une machination infernale
jusqu'à faire chavirer l'univers
confortable qui s'est construit
à côté c'est moi c'est vrai en algérie
oui l'algérie pu penser que j'aurais
aimé parler avec jp de cinq minutes
uniqlo en cinéaste phare de la nouvelle
vague du polar m à surprendre ses
acteurs sur le plateau ni moteur les
actions la caméra est en alerte pour se
dire la moindre émotion et même les plus
grands jouent le jeu
ma faire raser ma moustache que j'ai
accepté je crois que deux fois mais
comme par hasard cette fois avec need
you se retrouve dans un truc étrange un
univers qu'affectionne particulièrement
josiane balasko
elle a déjà tourné plusieurs fois avec
le réalisateur ryan mais si c'est une
fan de ses personnages mechelle varin
j'enquête sur le meurtre de richard de
vol il sait très bien faire les méchants
vieillot mais il a vraiment le talon de
faire exister des gens profondément
totalement noir noir et attachant aussi
parce que terriblement humain et c'est
peut-être ça m'a qui délivre midi avant
de refermer cette édition je vous en
rappelle l'une des principales
informations on l'a appris il ya un peu
plus d'une heure en colombie les
rebelles des farc annonce la libération
de trois otages parmi lesquels une
ex-collaboratrice d'ingrid betancourt
il y à quelques instants son ex mari
fabrice de loi nous indiquait qu'il
prenait l'information au sérieux et il
voyait un signe positif et inédit depuis
six ans c'est la fin de ce journal merci
de l'avoir suivi que de suite la météo
nathalie rihouet 20h50 le silence de la
mer un téléfilm adapté de la célèbre un
nouvel de vercors à demain
chance
l'info en continu c'est aussi sur france
2 point fr autres